bc one and zero many people have said
some similar sentiments please beta
access to jai i will pay 100 for access
we're you know we're working on rolling
it out wider it's been um
so one of my goals
in doing this language has been to solve
problems that
are happening with the way things are
currently done and one of those problems
is we have all this messy software that
doesn't really work and why do we have
that well people make stuff and they
don't work that hard on it and then they
give it out
and then they let for people
who are using it to run into problems
and then report the problems and like
well
meanwhile you have all these people
experiencing a lot of problems or
slowness or
unreliability right and if you
if your piece of software is very
successful add up all the time that
those people spent experiencing those
problems it's quite large right even if
imagine only a hundred people used your
thing and you cost them each an hour
that's a hundred hours right that's
three and a half weeks or no two and a
half weeks of full-time work so if you
could have fixed this problem
in let's say it would have taken you two
very hard days of work to fix this
problem that cost these people an hour
um
the the net benefit to everybody is
still a couple weeks right
now 100 users is a very
uh unsuccessful piece of software
actually right okay once you get to the
tens of thousands or millions
these factors are just insane how big
they are right and so what i'm trying to
do is
not create pollution of that kind
right i'm trying to not have negative
externalities so
we're starting with a small group we're
refining the language we're making it
better and we're slowly growing the
number of people right now there's about
100 people
and
i do want to start looking at widening
that soon
in some way that lets people
opt in
but i don't exactly you know we haven't
totally figured it out yet